Майже 90 років тому собор знищили більшовики, тепер - російські окупанти.
Ракета прилетіла в правий вівтар святителя Петра.
Бачите, він повністю зруйнований.
Також частково зруйновано центральний вівтар.
23 липня 2023 року. Російська ракета влучила в найбільший храм Одеси
- Свято-Преображенський собор.
Я був тут через 10 хвилин і побачив таку страшну картину.
Вся площа в уламках.
Собор - нема ні вікон, ні дверей, а двері тут величезні.
Він палає, дим.
І це був великий шок для мене й потрясіння.
Я взяв вогнегасник, щоб загасити.
Пожежа ставала дедалі сильнішою.
І я кинувся рятувати наші святині.
Загалом тієї ночі обстріли РФ зруйнували перекриття трьох  поверхів,
пошкодили внутрішнє оздоблення та ікони,
а також повністю знищили службові приміщення нижньої частини собору.
Собор увібрав у себе цю вибухову хвилю.
Все в ньому залишилось.
Він побудований за новітніми технологіями, дуже багато бетону.
Це все він все витримав.
І вся ця вибухова хвиля залишилася тут.
Та після удару ракети життя собору не зупинилося.
Поки верхній храм стоїть понівечений і обгорілий,
богослужіння проводять у нижньому.
Спасо-Преображенський собор - головний храм Одеської єпархії Української православної церкви,
пов'язаної з Московським патріархатом.
Тут донедавна молилися за патріарха Кирила, а у 2010-му він особисто освячував собор.
Чому Росія запустила ракету по храму,
який десятиліттями офіційно підпорядковувався РПЦ,
- питання, на яке тут не мають відповіді.
Я би хотів, щоб ви його задали тій стороні, що вони думають про це, що вони роблять.
Ніхто не може зрозуміти, навіщо ця війна,
які в неї цілі й від кого вони нас захищають та визволяють.
Росія вже не вперше атакує храми УПЦ в Одесі.
Приміром, у березні цього року удар прийшовся по чоловічому монастирю.
Тоді постраждало четверо ченців.
Та ані цей випадок, ані руйнування Спасо-Преображенського собору
не переконали релігійні громади УПЦ, донедавна пов'язаної з московським патріархатом,
приєднатися до Православної церкви України.
Від початку року в Одесі та області не відбулося жодного переходу.
Це мав би бути дуже сильний поштовх для того, щоб зрозуміти, що цей "руський мір"
- вже не мир давно, їм з ним не по дорозі.
Проте, напевно, тим священникам, які не хочуть переходити
і знову продовжують служити в так званій Українській православній церкві,
яка по факту є Російською православною церквою в Україні, Московського Патріархату,
далі там продовжують служити і проповідувати.
У зруйнованому Росією соборі кажуть:
Православну церкву України не визнають, тож і переходити до неї не збираються.
Який перехід? Куди переходити?
До кого переходити? У нас є своя церква, яка має 10 тисяч приходів.
Є свій предстоятель, є свій синод,
який має всі права, який поставляє єпископів.
Церква, яка варить своє миро.
Це всі ознаки незалежності церкви.
І дізнайтеся в тих, про кого ви мене питаєте, які в них є ознаки незалежності?
Загалом до Православної церкви України
на Одещині приєдналися лише вісім парафій УПЦ.
А у самій Одесі - жодного класичного переходу.
Люди, котрі бачать, що їх дурять і водять навколо пальця,
покидають такі громади і переходять до храмів Православної церкви України.
Цього року ми це могли бачити на Великдень, на Трійцю та на інші великі свята,
де в наших храмах кількість людей збільшилася в 5-6 разів.
Але є слабка сторона цього питання,
тому що саме ці люди є активними,
і саме ці люди могли би на парафіях організовувати кампанію
з переходу цілої парафії до Православної церкви України.
Наразі в Одесі діє близько сімдесяти храмів УПЦ,
донедавна московського патріархату, а ось храмів ПЦУ - лише п'ять.
Такий нерівний розподіл - це результат багаторічного російського впливу
й вливання коштів із РФ, вважає історик Володимир Демедюк.
Крім того, каже, є й інша - локальна причина.
Були періоди, коли священнослужителі Української православної церкви Московського патріархату
були депутатами Одеської міської,
Одеської обласної ради, інших місцевих рад.
Що це, як не зросійщення релігії влади?
Митрополит одесько-ізмаїльський Агафангел
московського патріархату був не лише на зорі незалежності
народним депутатом України, але і в 2010-х роках був депутатом
Одеської обласної ради від "Партії регіонів".
Так само настоятелька одеського Свято-Архангело-Михайлівського жіночого монастиря
Надія Шевчик, матушка Серафима,
була депутаткою Одеської міської ради від тієї ж політичної сили.
За таких умов храми тодішнього Київського патріархату
ледь виживали, розповідає секретар Одеської єпархії ПЦУ.
Ми завжди відчували гніт і тиск, завжди.
Несприйняття від влади, ми не могли увійти в кабінети.
Наприклад, мені один з чиновників в 2003-2004 роках,
коли я прийшов у рясі з Христом,
тоді я був секретарем єпархії також, і приніс документи на реєстрацію.
Вони мене поганяли по кабінетах,
і я висловив своє незадоволення.
Мені він сказав приблизно так:
"Послухай, пацан, якщо ти ще раз десь таке скажеш,
ти не те, що не зареєструєшся, ти навіть в цей кабінет не зайдеш".
Ось так ми приблизно жили. І коли ставало трохи легше,
коли ми могли зайти в кабінет, ми цьому дуже раділи і старалися щось зробити.
Проте тепер на тиск і гніт нарікають уже в УПЦ, пов'язаної з МП.
Так, 19 жовтня Верховна Рада підтримала у першому читанні законопроєкт
про заборону релігійних організацій, які пов'язані з РФ.
Це фактично запускає процес заборони УПЦ, пов'язаної з МП.
У свою чергу представники церкви наголошують,
що УПЦ є "самостійною і незалежною", а також вважають,
що законопроєкт "не відповідає Конвенції з прав людини та Конституції України".
Я вважаю, що в державі кожен повинен займатися своєю справою.
Журналісти - журналістикою, політики - політикою,
церква - церквою, молитися.
І ніхто не повинен нікуди лізти.
І тоді буде все добре.
І найголовніше, що в ці важкі й скрутні часи
треба всім навпаки об'єднатися, а нас беруть і роз'єднують.
Тим часом частково зруйнований Спасо-Преображенський собор
хочуть відбудувати.
За підрахунками будівельників, це може коштувати понад 200 мільйонів гривень.
Допомогу вже пообіцяла Італія.
Також чимало українців долучилися до збору коштів на реконструкцію.
Люди згуртувалися навколо собору
і ще раз підтвердили, що це улюблений храм одеситів,
якому вони готові допомагати.
І я впевнений, що з Божою допомогою одесити знову його відбудують.
Наостанок запитуємо, чи відреагували якось
на обстріл собору колеги-священники з Росії.
Вони писали, всі висловлювали співчуття на сторінках.
Зараз всі пишуть у соцмережах.
Там живуть такі ж люди, як ми.
І є якийсь відсоток людей, які розуміють цю безглузду війну.
Але вони нічого не можуть зробити.
Тому це дуже велика шкода, що християни воюють між собою.